When the alphabet first popped
up in the Mediterranean.
It was a single scratchy list of letters,
but no European alphabets have not
one but two symbols for each letter.
One big upper case and
one little lower case.
So I hear you ask why the
extra complications. How
did this resizing happen?
Gaze now with these sternly romantic,
Latin and Greek inscriptions with their
textured words that sink shallowly into
they're crumbling slabs. They look like
epitaphs for an ancient civilization,
but narrow your aesthetic focus and look
only at the letters. What do you notice?
Capital Letters.
It's all capital letters,
big imposing monumental capital letters.
Even when they took up softer media
writing on puff virus and parchment,
the Greeks and Romans pen their
words with these big letters,
this magic school script that's right
century's worth of all caps rage.
But the rise and reign of Christendom
brought with it the ascent of the book and
booksmith scribes with ink
flowing from their pens.
The large sharp angles of older scripts
gave way to smaller rounder fluid forms.
In the late seven hundreds Charlemagne
invited the scholar Alquan of York to his
court.
And this man shaped up the king's scribes
developing and teaching what we know
is Carolingian minuscule,
the most celebrated early Latin,
minuscule or lowercase script.
Around the same time,
Greek writers came up with
our own running cursive.
Handful of smaller miniscule letters
to Byzantine Greek had a particularly
strong minuscule tradition,
which dominated it's manuscripts.
For a thousand years, Latin and
Greek weren't traveling alone here,
Greek brothers Cyril and Methodius
tweaked their alphabet to make it suitable
for old Bulgarian in the eight hundreds
and so they gave birth to the cyrillic
alphabet.
Now,
cyrillic never developed the kind of
very distinct lowercase forums found in
Latin and Greek manuscripts,
but eventually it did distinguish
smaller and larger letter types.
Now at this point in our story,
notice that uppercase scripts and
lowercase scripts are different scripts.
We're not really mixing magic
skills with Munis skills here.
When did the modern mixing
start by cameral scripts,
ones that treat uppercase and lowercase
as variants of the same letter.
We're still on the horizon.
You can get hints of the system and
old writings like those larger capital
decorated initials that adorned
medieval manuscripts, but by cameral,
uppercase plus lowercase became the
standard when language is written with
alphabet, settled on employing
minuscule for most texts,
but using the magic skill letters
to signal important information.
A big letter at the
beginning of a sentence,
a big letter at the
beginning of a proper name.
We're even at the start of every single.
Now these have all been standards in
the history of English and the last one
still is for German, but not
all by cameral siblings. Agree.
Should you capitalize the name
of a foreign language or not?
Ken capital's fall in the middle of words.
Should you even capitalize the
first letter of every sentence?
Should you write some things entirely
in caps by cameral scripts don't have a
monopoly on different
forms for a single letter.
Maybe we'll save the details for another
day because I always like doing these
comparative of sides,
but think about Syriac and later,
but very similar to Syriac Arabic.
These cursive scripts
don't have capital letters,
but each of their letters have
up to four distinct shapes.
Initial in the letter connects to the
start of other letters medial when it
connects between two letters final,
when the letters connected to the
end of of their letters in isolated,
when it's all alone, there's even a
cool acronym for these. They're in fees,
scripts,
and well,
sometimes the difference between IMF I
forms is pretty small in scripts that are
as maniacally cursive is Syriac in Arabic,
it's very important.
So maybe by cameral in empty scripts
are both part of a broader phenomenon.
How a single letter can have multiple
standard variants within a script,
but still be the same
letter in the same script.
It's interesting to think about. It's
a good question. Thanks for asking it.
But now that we've tackled the
uppercase and lowercase letter variants,
and now that the word by camera rolls
off your tongue and makes you sound even
smarter than you already were,
I want to move on to another
story of Latin letter variants.
It's a tale of ancient and
medieval letter modding. Modders.